extra motivation
to win this tournament and also we have
a niche gear here also having some
conversations with him in ohs he wants
to be in miami ah how about you david
who does favorite
just because he's in great form uh i'm
going to say teamwork about that yeah i
think one of the oh at least one of the
three candidates it just feels like
being match fit is going to be so
important in this type of quick format
uh rajabov meanwhile just closing his
eyes there but is that a picture of
himself behind him as an astronaut
i mean it looks a bit like him
either way i'm going to say even if he
might not be the favorite in this game i
think timo rajabov he's shown it before
last year he won an event on the tour
he did very well in the tour finals
i'm to say he's going to be up now yeah
both of these players have shown that
they are capable of winning tournaments
on the meltwater champions chess tour
and we do know even more is at stake
right now because this is the final
tournament before the next major which
will take place with all players
on site in miami in florida which sounds
nice to be there in the sun
and maybe these two players will qualify
here we go the tournament has started
and we have the first moves we have the
first moves it's a king's pawn opening
it's the spanish opening uh the roy
lopez and okay no berlin endgame no
quick berlin draw that's a relief
we know that duda is a very fighting
player meanwhile your vancouver's
prediction is correct rajabov with this
opening choice just trying to be solid
as black just trying to survive the
opening and white is the first to castle
sooner or later duda will start
advancing white's pawns forward in the
center increasing the tension there
early days this is the position i've had
many times myself though and black is
very solid
for now all pieces on the board though
and it's going to be a long game a tense
game
how is duda going to get his pieces out
we did learn a lot about openings in the
previous tournament the chesable masters
so what opening are we looking at here
so it's uh it's a variation of the
spanish opening we would call it an
anti-berlin
so black was trying to play the berlin
defense the berlin wall where he's rock
solid queens come off very early but the
reason it's an anti-berlin is white
didn't allow all those exchanges white
didn't allow the berlin defense
so okay pieces are just developing now
and in the spanish opening in the
italian opening which is kind of a
cousin to this type of
this type of setup it's all about
maneuvering it's all about where to put
the pieces how to push
kind of your pawns on either flank later
on
both sides of castle now both sides got
their pieces on very nice squares yeah
and
now the kind of question for black is
how are they going to okay if we see him
move i mean the real issue for me is uh
whether white will manage to go forward
in the center with a pawn if not then
kind of the energy transfers to the
pieces and uh raj above kind of keeping
it tight
yeah rajabov keeping it tight if you
look at black's pawns especially this
last pawn push black has made
around the black king he's just trying
to cover all the squares in his half
he's not necessarily trying to push
forward while ivanka has mentioned there
will be a key break and we'll look out
for it after this light uh last night
move
wow i was going to say white is the one
going for a pawn break white really
wants to push this pawn forward to the
center if black had been slow for
example just a nothing move then
suddenly white pushing forward would be
fantastic for duda duda establishes
these really strong pawns after a trade
for example these pawns would dominate
the center dominate the game but rajabov
says no just before
you get the opportunity to push your
pawn i'm gonna do the same and black
pushes forward
i'm incr i'm incredibly impressed you
played this move uh made this decision
so quickly but the idea is after a pawn
trade now black still has more space in
the center this stronghold
decently protected i think by black's
rook by black's bishop and knight all
protecting this pawn in the center of
the board and meanwhile white is the one
lacking space so
great play i think from timor rajabov
this pawn wasn't captured white is going
to keep the tension here and duda
decides to just try and gain some space
this is a very magnus carlson-esque type
of move trying to push this pawn as far
down the board as possible in readiness
for an end game later but also just
trying to clamp down on black structure
on this side yeah
i love this type of long-term strategy
it looks like a kind of non-kind of porn
move but then it becomes so good in an
in-game as you mentioned and
well rajab says no i don't want the hat
and instead ask the question to the
bishop are you going to capture the
knights probably not or are you going to
take a step back
i i would definitely keep my bishop yep
it wouldn't even be a question there why
is dude opposing though normally in the
spanish opening you nearly never ever
want to give up your light squad bishop
for a night unless you can double your
opponent's pawns but uh here if the
white bishop takes the black knight
black just recaptures with this bishop
very healthy position there
so is duda thinking of maybe trading a
set of pawns in the center
i mean why not just step back that
bishop one square looks very healthy
very sensible yeah uh looks like a good
choice i mean i hadn't even considered
porn taste porn but uh after commenting
on prague hernandez games i should
always be on the alert for those kind of
counter-attacking moves uh very
difficult to spot but at the same time
once you get into the habit of
calculating them they kind of really
become like second nature and uh there
we saw the sun streaming down on duda's
face because it is summer
[Applause]
it doesn't look like it from june but it
is summer it is summer and then we'd see
the move that you suggested porn takes
porn um okay now the calculation has to
come on and we have to work out what's
going to happen after pawn takes bishop
or alternatively
like uh just captures the pawn with the
knight yeah two choices here for raja
above uh maybe we can show ivanka
mentioned two moves there
white has just captured opponent center
either you can just recapture the pawn
and say okay nothing much has changed
it's just a fair exchange or you can say
let's get uh ambitious now take this
bishop off the board and after white
recaptures uh a knight suddenly it's
level material after a couple of uh
trades there but the question is can
white grab a pawn in the centre of the
board this pawn is only protected once
it's attacked twice however so knight
takes pawn does look like it wins upon
at least temporarily for black black
might have compensation for example if
the bishop moves due to the fact this
bishop is now unrivalled it's on a great
diagonal uh pointing down towards the
white king later this is quite a typical
kind of pawn sacrifice but
judging by rajabos style he won't go for
it he doesn't really need to sacrifice
the pawn at the moment i think uh in the
current position if he just recaptures
this pawn this is the first option i
mentioned earlier then he's got a very
healthy
um kind of structure here white's bishop
still attacked white's bishop now will
not take this knight because this pawn
is defended sufficiently it's also
defended by the bishop
so white can't take so i think duda
instead of taking that he'll just step
back with his bishop hitting the knight
in the center ivanka are you surprised
by how quickly they've both played it's
already 13 moves down the line not the
typical kind of uh maneuvers i don't
think this is opening preparation yeah
i'm i'm very surprised you know they've
taken a lot of committal decisions you
know first of all rajabov
playing that pawn break in the center so
early and so so quickly as well you know
because did he calculate this i mean
this is all forcing stuff i mean
do they know the consequences do you
think they have opening prep from the
candidates when they played each other
that they maybe are using well i i
checked the database this is rare stuff
this has never been played before so you
know both both players are freestyling
it but they're freestyling in a very
confident
manner and there we see
i've never seen that posture from him
have you yeah i mean we've seen him
close his eyes kind of lean back like a
jedi and just meditate but he looks like
he's falling asleep
i mean it's been a busy week busy couple
of weeks yeah for both these players
with the candidates madrid traveling
home afterwards recovering
so uh
i think that's why i'm surprised they
were playing so quickly i was expecting
maybe them just to
kind of slowly find their way into this
game but it turns out rajabov he is
awake he's just leaning back and making
this big decision so we showed those two
different lines he's just choosing he's
weighing up the pros and cons between
those two variations comparing them
deciding what to go for one of them is a
pawn sacrifice for black i said it's not
his style but he's considering it maybe
ivanka yeah i think he definitely is
just uh by him taking a pause you know
he's trying to see the bigger picture
and uh just trying to enjoy what's in
front of him and the reason i mentioned
enjoyment because you know it is the
summer of chess you know we're the ftx
summit of chess and we love it when
everyone at home gets involved in the
conversation joins in the fun tweets us
their questions their comments and also
their selfies and you can do all that by
tweeting us using the hashtag
chesschamps and remember we will try and
feature them on the show
and the ftx summer of chess could be
even more exciting for all the fans if
you go grab your free
ftx key and you can do that by for
example using that qr code that you see
on the bottom of the screen right now or
if you head to
ftxcryptocop.com you can claim a free
key which will give you access to a
bunch of cool content competition prices
all the way up to a hundred thousand
dollars will be given out for the ftx
summer of chess so go claim your free
key
and i'm gonna do that as well yeah
nothing better than free stuff i know
i know and the chance to win
you know a bunch of money
yeah that's always good and also it's
very nice being part of the community
yeah and this is one of the things that
i've actually adored um just by because
of my job as the commentator on the
championship you know how many people
just join in the conversation they send
me messages i try and reply as often as
i can and it's a real loving and very
active very friendly community yeah and
just you can do the same in ftx and if
you can combine money chats yeah it's
great combination that's what we all
dream about yeah
yeah and you are also very good like i
follow you on twitter for example
sometimes you share puzzles for example
which is always a lot of fun there's
going to be puzzles as well um
in this community that's i love that
about chess you know challenge each
other with small puzzles from time to
time yeah i know i mean it's actually
great because the last two i actually
started since just sharing a few puzzles
that really impressed me and suddenly
you know everyone was sharing that
positive well i shared it from someone
else to be honest and then they shared
it on and they spread the message
because we can all enjoy chess beauty
yeah and uh the second was actually on
my insta and that was like there's
actually a story behind it so in the
late naughties i can't remember when a
french teammate of mine he showed me
this puzzle
it was fantastic you know i think i'd
had a terrible chess weekend but i saw
this puzzle we solved it together oh we
see porn we see the sacrifice on the
board yeah rajabov giving up a pawn and
actually all of the moves we showed
previously right now white is one point
up but black has the bishop pair
especially black's light square bishop
in the center of the board is going to
be a great piece but meanwhile ivanka uh
you were saying
yeah i was talking about
past solving puzzles and i mean one of
the great things about solving puzzles
is that you give up material and
yeah this puzzle was just amazing it
haunted me for years and it annoyed me
so much that i never knew the composer
and then
and then i found it i found it a few
days ago really it was actually in the
master your chest dude pogba book and i
found it i literally jumped up for joy i
shared it with all my friends and also
shared on instagram wow that's so cool
all right we do have a few moves so
i'm guessing it's heating up in the game
who are you liking it for now then david
it's definitely heating up and i'm gonna
sit on the fence kaya i'm really not
sure um i like what black's doing just
from a kind of
idealistic standpoint black has this
fantastic bishop in the center of the
board but then again white is very solid
for now and white has an extra pawn if
we do a quick count white has these four
um sorry not that square uh white has
these four pawns against black's three
and these black three are slightly
compromised as well there are double
pawns rajabov meanwhile pushes a pawn
forward trying to utilize a pin on the a
file white's pawn cannot take of course
because the rook would fall off uh
behind it but in the current position
for example if duda pushes this pawn
forward
maybe this pawn won't survive uh long
term it is a bit of a weakness it's an
intruder in the black camp but it will
take rajabov several moves to go and win
it
and uh in the meantime white does have a
strong pawn center
i'm going to say i prefer black slightly
but
at the same time maybe more
materialistic players would say white so
how about you ivanka in the current
position
white does have this question to answer
of this pawn attack twice that's a nice
move by raj above i didn't see it at all
um
putting pressure on the weak spot
because like you say
you know suddenly black has a target
what's white plan i don't know what's
planned what if he just moves it one
square up yeah he'll do that but i think
rajabot will as david mentioned just
hunt down that pawn
and slide across
and then the big issue is
yeah you know white has this amazing
central knight on the e5 square but the
knight sitting on the g3 well that's
dominated by black's pawns and the dark
square bishop doesn't really have a good
point to look at either um
yeah the mvp the most valuable piece
here is definitely the bishop in the
center of the board it's got its eyes on
this diagonal this diagonal is
controlling everything and it's the only
unrivalled bishop
in the position in order to win this
pawn remember white had to give up his
light squad bishop for a night
so uh yeah for example if white tries to
keep his pawn alive here push it forward
even further then this is actually the
ideal setup for black look at this the
queen and bishop dying down against the
white king side now white's king is
actually not easy to defend you're gonna
have to make some ugly moves to defend
this pawn uh and also meanwhile this
white extra pawn is not uh is not gonna
stay on the board for much longer it is
about to drop off
so yeah maybe rajabov did have this plan
in mind the whole time if we backtrack
to the current position if you don't
push this pawn forward and kind of
offer it up just kind of step into no
man's land then the only other way to
save it is to push this pawn but this is
ugly because suddenly
this is a backward pawn and i can't see
a way to actually take advantage of it
right now but
uh yeah somehow this pawn structure now
for white is very ugly you can never
push this pawn forward to attack black's
bishop because uh this square is an
outpost that black will control yeah no
i i don't like that a poor move at all
you mean you're handing all the light
squares to black on a silver platter and
you're like no i don't like it um
the only thing that i can think of and
i'm just thinking back to something that
you you said once that you know when you
have
when you're fighting against the bishop
pair you have to accelerate the play so
therefore
just try to kick back the light square
bishop maybe because that's my that's my
thing push pawns i want to go push the b
pawn one square yeah that makes a lot of
sense actually ivanka so for example if
black
takes this pawn now restoring the
material balance then suddenly at least
white gains a lot of time
we could see an exchange here and
suddenly at least this bishop is forced
backwards
maybe it can still stay on this great
diagonal but at least white's kind of
got this nice pawn center now white can
start developing his bishop out i'm not
sure exactly where maybe to the long
diagonal maybe even to this one
and the game goes on black has the
bishop pair but white has maybe the
slightly better structure
so uh yeah it's just it's all about
taste here do you want the bishop pair
do you want an extra pawn do you want
the better structure long term the
players they've just got to go for what
suits their style more where they feel
more comfortable it's roughly balanced
and the compute computer the evaluation
bar above the board saying it's roughly
level but everything to play for
and uh yeah the more i think about it
the more i like rajabot's choice not
just locking down the position taking
the kind of easy way out radio bot's
going for something very double-edged
and dude you can see is reacting to that
now with a four minute think that's a
long long thing wow and
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if he
thinks a bit longer because this is a
real critical situation if black wins
the pawn back and doesn't have to give
anything in return then black simply has
an advantage with the bishop
and david i was just going to ask you to
read the body language of doola though
because he looked out of the window
is he happy not happy he's looking for
inspiration he's hoping the sun's
shining in on him that
you know some great move will pop into
his mind suddenly the sun's shining on
the square
oh okay
exactly exactly i mean if he plays an
amazing move now then we'll know where
it came from
has that ever happened to you during a
game oh like you've got a sign like i
should move this piece no
i think it lost it at some point but it
must have been like some divine
inspiration somewhere
i'm trying to think no i mean there was
one time where
this is really embarrassing but this is
when i was really really young and i
didn't realize it was rude to eat at the
board so i was eating a sandwich that my
mum had made me i think i was maybe
eight or nine and then a piece of
lettuce dropped and then it went on the
piece and i kind of touched the piece to
get rid of it and then my opponent said
touch move oh no so i had to move that
piece and it turned out it was quite
good
it wasn't the best move but it was quite
a good move
and i ended up winning anyway i'm not
sure that was divine inspiration or luck
because i was already winning
um
yeah there are some these things into in
chess they do happen sometimes you do
read about uh yeah stranger things than
that yeah i know magnus has sometimes
like opened
with a move like according to maybe the
seat he was on on the plane maybe like
one this is b or whatever um and i mean
when he was when trump was just elected
and he he was playing in new york he
played the trompovsky variation and
plays the london system when he's in
london
uh he plays the scandinavian opening
because he's scandinavian magnus so
chess players they do look for these
patterns these signs um
yeah i'm not sure how much i would say
be superstitious because being
superstitious definitely comes with its
drawbacks
but uh yeah just
as actually as we'll maybe find out the
bobby fisher story he was very very into
these signs and
he was very into these signals and
yeah he would find links between real
life
stuff he's heard and stuff that happens
on the chessboard but
yeah in general i think it's best to
just calculate and trust that
yeah more than anything and after more
than six minutes here comes the pawn it
pushes forward
and we're gonna see rajabov hunt that
pawn down just slide the queen to the
side as david indicated or would forgive
something else um
i don't see anything else it's just a
pretty much a one track
plan or one track mind is what i wanted
to say
yup i guess you can maybe make an
argument for black's rook just stepping
down one square to blockade this white
pawn with the idea of black's queen
sliding to the corner
but it feels a bit slow and there we go
this was the most logical move
for black i'm just swinging the queen
across white's a pawn now is going to
disappear any moment but
this is the moment we've been waiting
for when in doubt push the h pawn that
is the motto of all the top players
nowadays especially in rapid chess and
white's h pawn has gone two squares
forward
and wow rajabov just blocks so the two h
pawns now blocking each other but this
has left some weak squares in both camps
i don't like oh and roger last move i
mean
it just looks awful actually because you
know you've weakened yourself on the
dark square there you go consequences
he's put his bishop on that square but i
mean
ideally
i mean i i would be a would have tried
to maneuver a knight to that uh square
g5 yeah um rajabov weakening himself and
if we jump in we can try and figure out
what just happened there so yeah black's
queen was attacking this pawn and uh now
this pawn is destined to drop off anyway
it's not going to survive long so duda
this is very good chess strategy he
switched the play to the opposite flank
while black's pieces are distracted on
the queen side and uh he pushed forward
on uh with his h pawn trying to push
forward again for example if we do see
rajabov get greedy and grab the pawn
back then suddenly this pawn would be
really really annoying for rajabov to
deal with if he pushes forward trying to
bypass that pawn then suddenly the white
knights jump in this knight on f5
fantastic piece
supported by its mate over here and
these two pieces together are just going
to cause all sorts of damage so i
understand why rajabov didn't want to
allow the advance of this pawn one
square forward he blocked it off but as
ivanka said it weakens first of all this
square which the white bishop jumped
into but
if you could somehow get this knight to
that square that would be ideal and uh
there are also ideas at some point later
um maybe not now it's a bit weakening
but this white pawn could start forward
uh start pushing forward trying to
undermine uh this weakness
especially while black's pieces are
gravitating towards the left side it
feels like uh now is the moment but
instead okay dude i brought his bishop
forward to the weakened g5 square and
now rajabov is stepping back
so maybe a threat in the position black
wants to push this pawn and fork the two
white minor pieces hitting the knight
hitting the bishop at the same time for
example if white's queen steps forward
maybe you could consider this one it's a
bit weakening for the black king but
this would win a piece at least
so in the current position what will
uh what will do to do he needs to maybe
move one of these two pieces away to
walk away from that double attack
ah there are ideas however just looking
at it of white sacrificing a knight at
some point i'm not sure it works right
now but you could definitely imagine a
situation where white sacrifices a
knight just to get the queen into the
attack i don't think we'll go for it
right now because black has enough
defenders around the king but watch out
for that one later yeah i
know you highlighted that idea i'm
thinking oh step back with the bishop we
will rook out for a sec sack okay
instead we have a decision i'm a bit
surprised by that decision actually i
was expecting the bishop to retreat
instead we see the night centralize
itself take a step back yeah it's
dropped back i guess it wants to maybe
re-route to this square to attack this
bishop kick it away from the center of
the board also now there's some tension
on the e-file meaning that maybe black
doesn't have enough time due to that
tension to go and grab this pawn in the
corner of the board so notice how dude
is just trying to distract rajabot as
long as possible so that rajab doesn't
have time to go and capture this white a
pawn
uh it's really really complicated right
now if rajabov can go and win this pawn
for example if he can take it over the
next couple of moves then he's just
doing great as black but if he doesn't
have enough time then of course this
pawn is going to be
just a
nuisance for him to deal with later it's
going to be a potential winner for duda
it's uh yeah it's the key moment now i
think just how does rajabov deal with
this central tension for example if he
swaps the rooks and then goes to try and
win this pawn then suddenly after a rook
exchange the white queen will get into
the heart of the black position and
suddenly uh oh this is a check it's not
the end of the world but it looks very
very scary uh for example the knight
could jump back maybe to block maybe you
can get away with this but uh i think
you have to go for something like this
as rajabov if you want to win your pawn
back you can't win this pawn back
right now we should mention because
suddenly the black queen is overloaded
she's defending both her rooks and one
of the rooks will drop for example after
a rook takes rook check then suddenly
the queen has been deflected away from
the protection of its other
so is this what
team rajab should have gone for earlier
he he should have taken that pawn
earlier but now it's maybe too late
right now i think it's yeah it's too
late right now to capture this pawn it's
just about whether he can maintain the
tension even longer and
kind of save it for later it's like when
you write a to-do list it's like how
long can you delay it before it's too
late when is the deadline when do you
have to capture that one i can relate to
that
[Laughter]
yeah i think this capturing that pawn
it's been on his to-do list for what is
it five moves now but
uh he's left it a long time yes getting
close
i've i heard it was a good philosophy if
you want to improve your imagination
just to kind of act as though you have
all the time in the world
aha you know like you have a deadline
just behave as though you've got it you
know the deadline that's going to be in
10 years time and then you actually find
that you get more creative and you do it
apparently
but they do say that you should combine
that with something that they call
urgent optimism okay
which is so basically that you know you
should be optimistic but again you have
to act you know you might not get a
second chance to be so positive so and
ivanka that's quite useful for chess
right because when you're looking for
attacking ideas especially if you
sometimes the best way is to look oh if
my opponent does nothing if i get four
or five moves where do my pieces want to
be if i have all the time in the world i
get four moves my rook wants to be here
my bishop wants to be here and that's
how you start planning of course you
have to take your opponent's plans into
consideration and kind of calculate it's
a race between your plans your
opponent's plans but yeah having all the
time in the world it's a nice luxury
and
well a load of trades the rooks have
come off and now the knight has trade
itself for the bishop so now we've got a
unique situation of bishop pair versus
night pair
and
what do you think about this rook takes
pawn
well rajabov is kind of confident that
his bishop player will be able to do
some defensive mastery
yeah so he has won his pawn back he can
finally check that off the to-do list
but now after a rook exchange which i
think we're about to see happen
suddenly the black queen is on a poor
square and duda okay he just moved his
hand back down to the mouse he does
exchange these rooks
is it time for white's queen to jump all
the way up to the top of the board to
give a check this is something we
mentioned earlier or potentially if duda
wants to play it safe he could move one
of his knights and let's jump in it's
level material now balanced again as
ivanka mentions
two nights against two bishops but uh it
is about which pieces are superior and
it's so tempting just give a check why
not hit the king
if the black bishop drops back and
blocks then this bishop is at least
pinned it's immobilized and it will be
for the next few moves
but if the black king goes to the corner
of the board it looks pretty safe
however this pawn is now weakened it's
defended by black's bishop and i'm just
looking at ways you could maybe start
attacking a few pawns you could attack
this bishop now you could attack this
pawn
you can attack this pawn it's kind of a
multiple attack maybe you can even bring
the white knight into the attack
hitting this bishop this key piece
remember that's holding everything
together for black
i mean this is just too tempting for me
but the other thing duda might be
thinking about other than giving this
check with his queen is to play his
knight over this way and this is a
double attack hitting the queen and
bishop and this would at least guarantee
that you get rid of black's bishop pair
once the queen moves then we could see
an exchange here and now it's just
knight against bishop only one set
but
white is maybe left
with this poor knight that ivanka
highlighted earlier
yeah i was going to a great piece i was
going to say dudeo is going to make that
uh knight
attacking move attack the forking the
queen and bishop if he's not feeling
very optimistic about his position
that's kind of for me is a bailout line
this is safety first just trading off
one set of pieces and then maybe
centralizing the white knight putting it
in the center here
but long term i see problems here for
duda because if you look at all of his
pawns they're on dark squares they could
be targets for the black bishop later on
so
i don't like this option as ivanka says
it's safety first approach that's not
dude's style he needs to go on the
attack therefore why not give a check
with the white queen i think this is
what he should go for
and uh with five minutes he's just
mulling up the two options he's maybe
just plucking up the courage to go all
out on the attack and remember queens
get on really well with knights when
they're attacking they're the dream
attacking combo because knights are the
only way only pieces that can move in
ways the queens can't
and yeah i just love this idea just
going to kick away this black bishop and
maybe the one downside the one scary
thing about this is the black queen can
sometimes sneak in behind and start
checking the white king but uh for now
the white king at least has one safe
square to hide on so this shouldn't be
too worrying for uh for white
so what do you think will it end up with
a winner or a draw this game
if duda gives the check with this queen
i think we'll see a winner okay we'll
see duda
but
okay he does it does it
and uh okay
i'm expecting the king to move and it
does and i really like this night move
because it also over protects every
single potential weakness that white has
i'm thinking of that pawn sitting there
on the light square on g2 yeah
protected my friend you can't attack it
no more checkmating ideas for black any
time soon black's queen is also terribly
placed so even though the black queen
can come down and give a check on the
first rank like we showed it's just one
check for now and also rajabov has some
serious questions to answer where to put
the black bishop
i don't like it for black suddenly if
black had one more move just before this
bishop was attacked just before this
knight jumped forward then i think
rajabot was doing great but
it's all about time it's all about tempo
as they say in chess and
right now where does this black light
squared bishop run to if it runs over to
this half of the board then it's offside
it's no longer centralized and the other
white knight can start jumping in
towards the center
ivanka do you think the momentum's
turning now totally i mean i mean i
think sudo's position is just great i
mean he can't even
think about going on the counter attack
and attacking this knight on g g3 by
pushing the h pawn but
yeah everything is kind of falling apart
yeah you mentioned going on the counter
attack hitting this knight that would
make some sense except for maybe just
the knight taking the bishop and
in this position not getting greedy and
capturing this pawn because suddenly
whoops there would be a checkmate on the
back rank this king would be trapped but
instead i think you mentioned just
taking back this pawn and
yeah white king despite the weird kind
of aesthetic value of these three double
uh kind of triple pawns now white's king
will be very safe hiding behind them and
okay we did see a couple of other moves
so this bishop didn't in fact run away
rajabov counter-attacked he brought his
queen back to try and offer a trade of
queens uh the black queen is defended by
her bishop and suddenly duda grabbed a
pawn he's a pawn up again
this has been the theme of the day so
far for him he grabbed one of black's
double pawns and after the bishop
stepped back
suddenly another attack every move dude
is attacking something and rajabov has
dealt with that by centralizing his
queen so rajabov has kind of regrouped
protected everything but it's come at
the cost of one pawn so now again duda
in the driving seat and first question
to me is
can you just push your pawn forward
maybe attack this bishop and try to grab
the pawn behind it when the bishop moves
that's one question you've got to be
careful though because uh the king is a
little bit unprotected yeah white's king
doesn't have too many defenders so for
example if the queen is attacked maybe
now greed is not good um actually
there's a couple of reasons i spot but
one of them could be suddenly this
bishop comes to life and double attacks
the white queen and both of the white
knights this is a horrible situation for
white you will lose a piece
so uh yeah maybe too many downsides with
that one maybe you just need to keep
these pawns
kind of intact right now just to block
out this uh this black bishop
so if not that then how do you
consolidate what would you do as white
one move that i would want to play at
some point maybe now or later is to just
hide my king
away from any potential checks in the
corner
maybe you can make an argument for
moving this white knight into the center
as well i kind of want to jump it into
this square to give a check
later on
it's
it's difficult choice now actually for
do that it's not it's not easy because
there are a lot of attacks that rajabov
has in the air you know you highlighted
the bishop attacking the queen i'm also
thinking of going back to an original
idea of the pawn stepping forward and
asking questions to the knight
um
and of course
duda always has to be thinking about
what happens if the black queen dives
into the position gives a check to the
white king so
a lot of danger somehow and uh i think
doodle has to be thinking about ways to
consolidate i must admit i am still kind
of swayed by your pawn attacking
attacking the bishop
i think he just has to tread a little
bit more
accurately and then yeah maybe actually
here instead of grabbing this pawn as we
saw that would backfire uh maybe the
queen could just slide across off for an
exchange and
maybe this is the way to keep control
queens are very good in the center and
uh at queen exchange here at least white
has no risk white is a pawn up i'm not
sure you win because black's bishops are
strong but you are a pawn up and instead
a different move and what do you think
of this one ivanka um after black's
queen came across
threatening maybe this check white has
guarded against that check by dropping
his knight back
this looks a bit odd maybe because
black's queen for example can centralize
trying to line up on the square you
mentioned it's protected so
one thing you don't want to do is move
the knight away because whoops this is
checkmate but actually maybe here this
doesn't work because white's queen can
just take this pawn defending the knight
and the key thing is the knight defends
the g2 square so um yeah maybe not
possible for black yeah
i'm uh a little bit baffled by that move
you know i know we kind of say that the
knight is the king's best friend and
everything so people will be like yeah
why are you guys not saying this is a
great move um but it does feel a little
bit passive and uh
and raj above now will be thinking about
uh ways that he can put pressure on the
white queen
yeah all right well the bar is over to
young christophe duda side he has almost
three minutes left on the clock
we do have the first result in the ftx
road to miami hans niemann the 19 year
old won the first game against fellow
american sam shanklin
and three points four hans niemann what
a start for the young american yeah
we're going to have to start calling
hans neiman the marathon man because he
actually played an over the board game
this morning really six hour games
over the board and then he jumps
straight into this tournament what uh
yeah he played a six-hour draw a really
difficult long queen end game nearly 100
moves uh in the german bundesliga and uh
i think he's had maybe an hour or two
break and then straight into this event
so
impressive from the youngster is
incredibly impressive because you have
to think you know playing a six-hour
classical game
for most people it's going to be
exceptionally tiring all they want to do
is sleep afterwards and he's gone
well he's playing one tournament to
another yeah he's gonna play for four
hours uh here as well yeah and i have to
say one thing about hans uh he's the
most improved player i think in the
world
well okay you know because he he made a
jump i think when i first heard of him
before the pandemic he was around about
2400 round just a bit uh higher rated
than me
and now he's like
wow skyrocketing yeah closing in on that
magical 2700 mark that's kind of that
shows the elite uh once you hit 2700 it
means you're one of the best players in
the world and
she's closing in and there's actually an
intriguing race i follow it on 2700
chess.com uh i think it's the top ranked
junior players so under the age of 20
farouza is number one by quite a
distance but
between places two and five i think
they've been switching places every
single day for the last uh two weeks
they're always winning a game they're
losing a game then catching each other
up and oh that's exciting it's as if
they're pushing each other pushing each
other to be better and it's all the
indian players and hans niemann
of the youngsters and hans nima well he
is born and raised in the u.s so
in america they must be very excited
about him
yeah i think khan's he's been
disappointed there hasn't been as much
recognition in the u.s from at least the
federation from
some tournament organizers as he feels
he deserves but
he's going to be in the us team for sure
sunday and
one of the most talented players i've
seen in a long time yeah and the u.s
needs to host their own olympia or not
their own olympia they need to host the
chess olympiad and then they can have
three teams two teams aha
yeah they have so many great players
right now sam shanklin one of them he is
in the us olympiad team but he lost game
one here two hans niemann now we do have
more moves coming in this game and you
did say earlier david you were
predicting a win for one player what is
it looking like right now yeah i'm gonna
stay true to that prediction just
because i have a feeling that this
position suits duda slightly more than
it suits rajabov because duda really
thrives when it's a bit imbalanced here
the main imbalance is the knight pair
against the bishop pair but also duda
has this extra pawn temporarily and with
this last move he's pushing forward
making his
move from victory and wow okay this is
all about counter-attacking now white
pawn attacked a bishop black's queen
counter-attacked against the knight a
lot of exchanges happened there in the
blink of an eye and one set of knights
and bishops have left the board
meanwhile duda still has his extra pawn
advantage right now if you look on the
left half of the board three versus one
porn advantage there for duda that is
potentially decisive meanwhile black has
a three versus two advantage on the king
side but white king is super safe right
now
and queen and knight are usually a
better duo than a queen of bishop so it
all looks like it's adding up in dude's
favor right now
ivanka any chances here for rajabov at
all he has to go for an attack against
absolutely um he has to at least
try and scare duda you know make him try
to kind of bully him with some mistakes
or some threats and
okay i think he's doing the right things
by pushing harry all the way to the
fourth rope maybe harry's going to go
all the way down to the third maybe the
bishop will come and join and threaten
some checks but uh duda he just seems
quite calm doesn't seem very fazed about
it at all
i mean if i were him i would would have
thought about centralizing the queen
because there's a queen in game queens
do great in the santa but no he's worked
it all out dude is the prince of
darkness uh according to his camera
right now but uh he looks like he's
going to win this game unless rajabov
can pull a rabbit out the hat and work
some miracles right now
i just don't see how he can disturb the
white king as you mentioned ivanka his
idea has been a good one pushing the
black h-pawn down the board but if you
push it any further it just gets
captured
there aren't really enough attacks
threats checks against the white king
white king can simply actually just run
away if it needs to
enough kind of shelter around it with
all the white pawns there and okay the
bishop and queen do line up the black
queen is now threatening to come down to
the h2 square
checking the white king
i say a threat the white king is just
gonna run it's not checkmate
and uh okay it runs anyway
why not you see your opponent's threat
just preempt it and laugh at them and
that's what dude is doing
i was just reminded of that line from uh
ghostbusters i ain't afraid of no ghosts
he's like queen and bishop lined up ah
it's nothing
you're not going to check me my night
covers everything and uh okay now it's
just a question of the white queen just
improvising to the right square
and uh well you can just see it there
right if rajaboff is forced to improve
his uh king
then there is nothing in the position
for black
and the clocks are ticking as well uh we
have another result wei
has uh won the first game against uh
vojtack who is also from poland same as
young christophe duda and it's
definitely heating up here in the first
round shakya and mamdiara fellow
azerbaijani 2 team raj above depart all
the way over to his side in that big
game against levon aronian oh and that
two young american players sam sevillan
and jeffrey jung they're both winning
their games as well the evaluation bars
all the way on their sides
so yeah lots of decisive games in this
first round geary struggling here in the
first game
wow already drama and it's only round
one in the fdx road to miami
exciting stuff and duda
his king isn't there he don't care the
white king is not getting checkmated any
time soon as ivanka mentioned just
centralized the white queen he can bully
above here with the threat of a queen
exchange because white is one pawn up if
the queen's come off white's three
versus one advantage on that side will
win the game
so rajabov he has to run away from this
exchange
unless he can maybe just exchange off
the queens and make a run for it with
the black king into the center of the
board but
i don't think he can try i just think
he's too slow and
wow he allows a queen exchange he pushes
a pawn forward
ivanka surely he's too slow here as
black totally right it's just a question
of counting now yeah it's a question of
counting and if we jump forward to the
current position white's queen stepped
back black's pawn push
we say it's about counting black is not
racing those pawns down the board time
soon and here after a queen exchange
say for example the white knight jumps
into the central board hitting this
bishop also hitting this pawn black's
bishop has to move and
i just don't see what is to stop jan
christoph duda pushing all of these
pawns forward this pawn this pawn maybe
to destabilize the bishop
it just like looks like uh an easy race
an easy win here for white
and here we go the queens have come off
the board i say easy there's still a
little bit of care to be done you need
to keep all your pawns on the board uh
as white you need to keep as many pawns
on the board as possible at least and uh
we're heading in this direction and
i'm not sure which pawn to push to be
honest it looks like you can push them
in any order you could even push maybe
this pawn forward just to stop black
from uh kind of uniting his three from
connecting these three guys
uh but to be honest i would just push
this okay yeah as duda has just done
push this pawn forward and uh
it's inevitable now these three pawns
together are going to win the game for
white yeah and uh rajapov running in
with his king and uh there we see the
idea that you mentioned
on the board and uh
the sad thing for rajabov is that even
if the black king takes one step forward
to attack the knight that knight's not
going anywhere you can just simply push
the sea porn and protect your own pawn
and look at that that night protects
everything now this knight is dominant
in the center for white and uh i think
we've got to check on the players now
because we could see a result any time
soon rajabov is he reacting he's down to
10 seconds on the clock he's got a
desperate situation on the board let's
resign or just make a random move what's
he going to do five seconds okay so he
attacks okay well duda supports the
knight this is complete domination right
now white tonight in the center of the
board a glorious piece and you simply
can't kick it away if you can't kick
away that night there's nothing else to
do and rajpov retreats as bishop white's
knight can go and grab another pawn now
do you think judo is going to be a bit
sadistic and try to run his king to the
right and try to win that h pawn yep why
not and here is white i think i would
simply grab black's pawn on the c7
square get rid of the remaining black
pawn on this uh on this queen side and
yeah as if i mentioned march the king
back where it came from g1 h2 h3
yeah that's just game over so
i think the problem here for dude is
that everything wins he just has to
choose a way that doesn't allow rajpov
any hope or any counter play
we've seen that gun go wrong before and
uh especially in time trouble but it is
a team rajabot with only 15 seconds on
the clock
dude now he spent most of his time on
this one move he's now down to around 30
seconds
he's just calculating he knows that no
matter how much time he spends now he'll
have worked out the next three or four
moves in advance so he can gain a few
seconds on the clock each time the
players do gain 10 seconds after every
move and there we go he eliminates one
pawn the white knight jumped back one of
the white pawns drops but now white
again has this barrier white's knight
defends
all the pawns and hivanka's plan in
action yeah the king is going to run and
attack the h4 pawn
and there it is
nothing to be done look at that knight
it protects every single pawn that could
possibly be attacked and rajabov
well
it's time isn't it
sadly
it's time for resign no you've had no i
think his last move is just very clever
rajabov he is going to try and exchange
off one set of uh pawns now on this
right side of the board i mean he's
still completely lost of course i think
dude is completely winning
but still a lot of hard work how does
white win
i yeah i'm not 100 sure about this plan
with the white king i think it just
takes too long i think he should have
gone to the center and that would have
been uh just as quick
but
okay if the white king steps forward now
one square to attack black's h-born
black will push his g pawn to protect it
well i think he's made the move and now
are we going to see some clever move by
duda i was thinking maybe retreat the
knight
okay he just uh runs with the b pawn
after all you got to keep pushing yeah
past pawns are there to be pushed as
they say and black's king is a bit
powerless black's king has to stop the
white knight and those two white
connected pawns he's going to be uh
overwhelmed
shortly
but can rajabov find a way if he can
exchange off all the white pawns on the
right half of the board white's f and g
pawns then he has a small chance
because then he could maybe hope to give
up his bishop for white's remaining
pawns
i mean that's a pipe dream that's so
many ifs in one sentence
but uh okay he allows the white king to
step forward
what is the idea there
white king can now just grab the black h
pawn
i don't see it i don't see it just uh
take the pawn yeah maybe dude is also
okay he does take the pawn eventually
and the black king stepping forward
maybe his idea is to actually
he wants to stop the white b pawn with
the black bishop and the black king is
going to try and grab some pawns as many
pawns as it can before the hammer falls
i just think it's too slow unfortunately
here okay there we go that is a very
strong past pawn white's king is coming
it's going to be a situation where white
is two pawns up most likely and can
black save that one it does feel like
dude is taking some risks though
white is running out of pawns yeah i
have to say you know
maybe i was too
too eager with my advocate resignation
policy because it does feel that maybe
there's some chance
it's you know
duda has to play a little bit accurately
now
so black's king is now going after the
white b pawn and look at the evaluation
but it's slowly starting to drop every
turn and it's all about whether white's
g pawn can run through here we go it
started the race if black can give up
his bishop for that white g pawn
it's a draw but the problem is the white
g pawn is so close to promotion and you
can only stop this pawn now with your
bishop on a dark square and
you can only stop it on the g7 square um
the black king is just too far away the
more i look at it the more i think you
can't stop this pawn
this is why he's running with the king
but okay unfortunately the bishop is
going to be driven back that's a really
bad diagonal look at it it's only got
two squares
and now is the time to start
you can go with your king you can go
with your knight to hit this black
bishop the black bishop has to go to the
edge of the board now only safe square
and yeah i think duda has seen that he
can just march his king around and
attack that bishop
that is going to be the end of the game
rajabov
he's falling to defeat here black's
bishop is powerless against this white
pawn
yeah nice nice idea there it was close
it was only by one move actually one
tempo but there we go duda gets the win